[Music]
hillbilly sports news submitted by all
of America catfishing the redneck
fishing tournament is one of the most
American pest control solutions in
existence when they grab with their
hands through that you know they get it
through the mouth and they're like
here's one of them like that where they
like will their fingers like it's a
little work
and they stick into these cracks in the
river and the [ __ ] catfish teeth into
its farms yeah I went through like a
straight-up binge of this like hand
[ __ ] catfish catch and think and I
think that's one of the dopest things on
points of they don't yell I got one
right supposed to have like [ __ ] bare
hands though I mean do it you really
I've never seen the lady where Wow
I saw the dads bringing their little
kids in and teaching the little kids all
the way up to the middle of their forums
they cover there are more like Chalmers
some [ __ ] cuz catfish like almost
anything they just go like this that's a
lot look like a worm sticking my hand
somewhere and not knowing what I'm
seeing
I agree the word get into the oceans
here cuz it's just dark right tell you
100% sure about this [ __ ] Gators
gonna be in there or whatever okay fish
has been a big problem in Illinois for
more than two decades which fish Asian
carp Pam yes I started swimming up north
along the Mississippi River with Asian
carp that's his koi right it's cause
quite fish yeah I don't know how it gets
in the system though but it does that's
crazy
yeah so then they've been eating away at
the local ecosystem and so they created
this woman it created a woman you know
this woman I'm starting my sentence
again now look BAM
Mellisa created this redneck fishing
tournament in 2005 to help deal with
this problem by trying to catch as many
as possible so what they do is that once
they hear the motors of the boats they
start jumping up and so this whole
tournament here is that these people
that are participating they have to use
whatever they can get - fishing poles to
catch these fish like nets so mainly
nets or garbage cans or whatever they
can get the helmet that is awesome
but catching good fish all day
yucky must be so stinking a lot dude me
what oh yeah
and so people from all over the place
join this tournament yeah I see him at
the Chinese market I just never knew how
it was like cooked or eaten you know
that's that's boy fish but it's not
fancy so what they did is like you know
how there's rice paddies and Asia and
stuff like that they would leave Karpin
therefore not only fertilizing but they
would eat this invasive little bugs and
all they're like the Roosters yeah
they're like the Roosters of the rice
fields and then they started breeding
like some of them would have nice color
and then they would just read them and
then they would make fancy koi yeah
but that's that's basically koi fish no
they're like these Killman domed yeah oh
no these guys yes example they don't but
in this I guess these guys might eat
them I don't know yeah they're saying
that they catch about roughly 50,000
pounds of Asian carp each year that they
do this tournament yeah because they
[ __ ] invasive that [ __ ] man I eat
everything like this year they brought
in five thousand eight hundred eighty
three fish Brahma
yeah they deep-fry in Korean cuisine
right because we don't eat carp in
Japanese we do but I feel like maybe we
use like soup we kind of really thin in
for sashimi carp yeah
so the reason why carp is really hard to
eat it has a lot of bones it's not a
really clean cut fish for people to
consume so even when they cook it in the
South they like a cornmeal and they'll
deep-fry it
and so the bones will come up and they
could pick it up so that's like a way to
prepare it
but specifically people like dog food or
something like they just catch them with
that's I thought before reaching their
hands and holes and [ __ ] no that was a
catfish oh man yeah see that [ __ ] that's
the cool [ __ ] man you can't describe
something that cool trying to guess what
it was because we said would you call it
redneck well redneck fishing right yeah
so that's what I thought it was you
can't get more Reznik to stick in your
hand and you know when we went to Japan
boy you know sorry I wasn't on the same
trip with you guys but I went to like a
theme park right and they trained their
koi fish to basically come up whenever
you like start throwing food and so you
could be on this boat and you just
surround it by [ __ ] koi fish and it
looks like the boat is being carried by
fish that much just [ __ ] fish around
you just keep beating them and [ __ ] and
like your condition that's crazy it's
pretty cool all right that's more like
it
damn that thing I was cheating he has a
glove on no yes huge a bracelet it's my
wedding bracelet oh my god holy moly is
that real
damn catfish get huge dude and the crazy
thing about fish is that fish grow to
the size of their environment yeah
there's some like River Monsters that
are like sometimes they just see it but
it's like the size of a shark the reason
why catfish can grow so big because
they're bottom-feeders and they
literally eat everything so they're
nutrition how much they eat is
ridiculous
yeah I mean have you guys seen that show
River Monsters yeah they go into the
Amazon or like yeah they try to catch
big [ __ ] like Amazonia feel that long
river but yeah why do they want to count
like that I think it's just like jollies
yeah it's it's kind of like I'll kill
the oldest things on earth catch and
release
yeah so they just heard it they stabbed
it a little bit and he stabbed their
lips open and then they release it
really catch them in a non hurt way well
they know he's a man they bring it to
life I've seen them like a net up and
bring it to shore just so you can see
and they uh there he goes again back
depending on the show what he'll do
could either scientists so he does it to
tag these animals to see how they live
in their environment yeah or if he goes
to a village and that's their main
source of food he likes to catch it and
give to the villagers oh yeah I back him
up I love that guy lobsters River is
like this lobsters like [ __ ] seven
thousand year they don't die right and
they wanted to eat or maybe not wait to
eat this guy right and then they were
gonna eat him and then this lady came
and bought the lobster and then let him
go
shoo barf like 300 bucks or some [ __ ]
it's just ridiculous I want to say that
I would eat it for the funnies but I
would let it go I respect man I'd be
like dude this thing was this old how do
you even get to tell of their age
there's probably it's more it's like a
tree wing yeah you cut his cloth for it
you can count the Rings whatever I
caught I mean we spend money every day
buying me so what we didn't mean an old
lobster he's been on earth for so long
bye and Grill lobster right he was here
with James Kate Polk was president and
you want to eat in the [ __ ] is James
capable he was one of the presidents of
the United States 7,000 years ago I
don't know I think to me it depends on
which lobster taste better this baby
lobster tastes better or is old lobster
tail
I think old lobster wouldn't a sent you
then I wouldn't eat those guys I'll try
to eat them little young be younger the
battery I think it's smaller supposed to
be better than bigger yeah eat the
little ones in it because if you go to
the market the bigger ones cost more
then wouldn't that mean those smaller
ones cost more yeah it's the opposite
the aquarium yep
pretty dark dude who gives me the 99
Ranch yeah my favorite petting zoo yeah
it gets pretty nuts there's another one
up here called shun fat it's even worse
they got [ __ ] tadpoles and frogs and
really they got some crazy I take it too
when it's called for why supermarket oh
dude that's big I read your slider
turtle they got softshell turtle day
they got tropical [ __ ] South American
fish like [ __ ] that way if you were like
oh cool we can put it in an aquarium you
get some rocks and like you'd be like my
little pet and you guys like no no this
other one I'll Garvey the [ __ ]
seafood one that specializes in crazy
ass [ __ ] that one is crazy so this one
has like I want like a literal pet store
it's like got like blue spotted [ __ ]
fish and it looks like you're an
aquarium and you could eat that [ __ ]
like snakes and [ __ ] and it's like for
eating no it's all seafood Oh big I like
these lobsters that have no claws and
[ __ ] it looks like cockroach lobster Wow
oh is that called alan cox kicking conch
langoustines
Langosta
why you're pointing at her stinking
Chinese nothing we ate at a Mexican
restaurant that handles they specialize
he had albino crab it was all white they
had the [ __ ] big long leg crab that
you always see frozen but then yeah but
it's alive everything you're talking
about yeah it was like [ __ ] Emperor's
seafood [ __ ] I got no problem eating
crab because they look like such mean
little [ __ ] they look delicious too
yeah see yeah yeah I could eat a crab no
problem yeah we used to go crabbing with
my family down in South Carolina can you
eat a turtle I know I could this smells
like [ __ ] dude oh really oh yeah it
looks like it would taste very good
what no I tried I visited my dad and his
family in China when I was in junior
high and I remember I was outside
playing basketball it's time to come
back home for dinner and the minute I
walked in the house I was like what the
[ __ ] is this smell and my dad's oh just
wait it's gonna be good and he brings
out a plate like this and there were
like a stack of four turtles and you
could tell they placed it nicely like in
45-degree angles because one head is
hanging like this the other head was
hanging like this and it just smelled
like [ __ ] and my dad he's like like
salivating we sat down on the table when
he cut one of the claws off he goes look
at this you know I got McDonald's like
hey yeah it's like that you never fed me
this [ __ ] ever in life how do you why do
you expect me to go cuz I look how juicy
this thing and then it's just like a
[ __ ] claw like all soft and jiggly
and I'm like I like that we're all like
oh how could they do that the turtle
arms like give me some chicken nuggets
with God knows what's inside yeah like
that for all I know there's [ __ ]
turtle and chicken nuggets for sure but
it's good turtle nugget
[Music]
[Music]